when we last saw him leaving hospital
he may have looked frail but prince
philip has been so perennial
such an enduring public figure that this
day
would always come as a shock
the notice outside buckingham palace
announced
it is with deep sorrow that her majesty
the queen has announced the death
of her beloved husband his royal
highness the prince philip
duke of edinburgh his royal highness
passed away peacefully this morning
at windsor castle prince philip earned
the affection
of generations here in the united
kingdom
across the commonwealth and around the
world
he was the longest serving consort in
history
one of the last surviving people in this
country to have served in the second
world war
at cape matapan where he was mentioned
in dispatches
for bravery and in the invasion of
sicily
where he saved his ship by his quick
thinking
and from that conflict he took an ethic
of service
that he applied throughout the
unprecedented changes of the post-war
era
we remember the duke for all of this and
above all
for his steadfast support for her
majesty the queen
not just as her consort by her side
every day of her reign but as her
husband
her strength and stay of more than 70
years
and it is to her majesty and her family
that our nation's thoughts must turn
today
because they have lost not just a much
loved and highly respected public figure
but a devoted husband and a proud
and loving father grandfather
and in recent years great-grandfather
speaking on their golden wedding
anniversary her majesty said
that our country owed her husband a
greater debt
than he would ever claim or we
shall ever know and i'm sure that
estimate
is correct so we mourn
today with her majesty the queen we
offer our condolences
to her and to all her family
during the pandemic the duke of
edinburgh has been in isolation with the
queen in windsor castle
which they dubbed hms bubble we've
caught recent glimpses of them together
on an anniversary card and christmas
card but coveted times
meant today's announcement was followed
by warnings to the public
that they should abide by social
distancing laws in paying their respects
but of course the flowers came along
with the tributes
well the uk has lost an extraordinary
public servant in prince philip
he dedicated his life to our country
and above all i think he'll be
remembered for his support
and devotion to the queen and all of our
thoughts are with the queen
the royal family and the british public
as they come together to mourn this
huge loss i always really really enjoyed
spending time with the duke of edinburgh
and talking to him of course i don't
pretend that i knew him well but i met
him
on many different occasions uh
particularly at
balmoral and he was very very different
to the public characterization
that we often heard and read about he
was a very thoughtful man
an exceptionally interesting man to talk
to
on behalf of the welsh government and
people in all parts of wales i offer
our deepest condolences to her majesty
the queen
her majesty's children and their
families
on this sad occasion prince philip was
widely respected for his active and
dedicated service to the country and for
his steadfast support to her majesty the
queen
throughout her reign he had a strong
interest in northern ireland
and i had the privilege of meeting him
here on a number of his many visits
she was head of state he was head of the
family
it was a partnership that won hearts
through service to this country
whatever your views on the monarchy it's
indisputable that the queen
is very popular she's brought a long
period of stability to the crown
and she couldn't have done it without
prince philip
the naval man gave up his calling to
steer
this ship and he's done it through 70
turbulent years once they were the
modern couple
lifting a country recovering from war
navigating the new media of television
nurturing as best they could a family in
the spotlight
he was the queen's ballast and closest
confidante
at six o'clock a bell rang at
westminster abbey
and it continued once every minute for
99 minutes
the number of years of his life my first
reaction
was to think of her majesty the queen
and to feel a deep sense of
sympathy and compassion
for her and for the whole family at the
loss of such
a gigantic figure particularly in her
own life
married for well over 70 years 73 years
prince philip's legacy will be in the
charities he supported
and especially the duke of edinburgh
award are you well sir
do i look ill always his own man
he helped draw up the details of his
funeral and was determined there should
be minimum fuss
plans will be restricted by covid but
the country will want to commemorate the
man
who managed to forge his own path as the
longest
royal support act in history to the
country's
longest reigning monarch jason farrell
sky news